[Music]
okay my name is Mike Seltzer I'm a
principal research in the speech and I
like research group at Microsoft and
what we're showing here today is
Microsoft's custom speech service this
is part of cognitive services
Microsoft's umbrella of services that
are available in our mission to
democratize AI research and development
so Microsoft has world-class speech
recognition our algorithms and models
are clearly state-of-the-art but for
some developers who have a different
need or have a particular application in
mind they may be able to get better
performance by customizing the models
and so this is very relevant if you have
an application with particular jargon or
vocabulary and it's also relevant if you
have an application deployed in a
particular environment so for example a
noisy factory floor so we allow you the
user to do or the developer to do is to
bring their own data and customize the
models to their application so the way
we do that is with this custom speech
service you can log in create an account
and upload your own data and so I'll
give you a quick example of a model we
built here this is for an application
we're pretending that this is a kiosk in
an airport and someone would go up and
want to get some kind of flight
information and you can imagine that the
terminal of an airport is very very
noisy and of course the vocabulary is
very specific to travel requests and so
we've basically taken that those things
and use that to customize the model and
so for example if we give a sample query
here you'll see that the request was for
something that's showing please show
only class queue and so you can see for
example here that the the baseline model
because it was very noisy it's not
possible you weren't able to hear it on
the video but it's very noisy utterance
that the baseline recognizer did a very
poor job whereas the custom recognizer
did a very good job and in fact that
allowed us to then get the intent of the
user very accurately can see here we
were able to figure out this is a flight
information request whereas here we were
unable to figure out what the intent of
the user is at all now in addition to
the various ways developers can do this
on their own we've also taken the
service and applied it to a PowerPoint
in a way that enables presenters to
basically have customized transcriptions
for all their slides so for example
here's a PowerPoint slide I took from
the web involving organic chemistry and
if I can start and what we do is we take
all the material that's in the slide all
the text and we use that we take to take
all the text to update the language
model the speech recognizer in addition
we do an intelligent crawl to go and
retrieve based on these words other
information from the web that can be
used to inform the model and so all that
happens that goes seamlessly behind the
scenes to build an updated custom
endpoint that can do a great
transcription of your material so I'll
do a quick example here forgive me I
don't really know anything about organic
chemistry although I will try to speak
about it here so the slides will show up
on this screen as you can see it asked
me to I want to customize the speech so
yes
the other interesting thing about the
trends the the project is that all these
transcriptions can also be transcribed
into many languages and you'll get this
QR card and people can log on on their
phones tablets or devices in the
classroom and get the transcriptions
locally on the devices in the same
language or translate into a number of
other languages so you can see if I go
here this is a lecture on
stereochemistry and I can come up to a
slide that has for example interesting
terminology like hybridized carbons or a
plane of symmetry and you can see up
here that we're getting these
transcriptions you know perfectly
accurate and this is a slide I like
because there's something here called
particular mirror image molecules called
enantiomers and I'm fairly sure that
things like enantiomers and stereo
isomers are not things you'd find in the
vocabulary have become a speech
recognizer but here it's critically
important for transcribing your slides
and so as a result we're able to do a
really good job
so that's been a demonstration of some
of the things you can do with the custom
speech service again the PowerPoint
presentation translator is available now
for public download and the Chris
service is also available for anyone to
go and give a try so I hope you enjoyed
that